JORDAN: Well, we're
gonna get started.
Thank you all for coming.
Really appreciate it.
I don't know about the majority
of you, but raise your hands
if you have investment property.
Raise your hands if you don't
have investment property.
All right.
OK.
So about a year ago,
I decided I wanted
to get involved in
investment property,
but the only thing that
I could find online
were a lot of
salesmen websites that
were trying to sell me a product
or go to Donald Trump's school
for $40,000, which is, in
fact, money I don't have.
So I went online and
checked Wikipedia,
looked for numerous websites to
educate myself on real estate,
and I eventually came
across BiggerPockets.com.
And by using the website,
what was amazing is
they have a community based
upon real estate investment
with investors who come from
all different walks of life,
from people who are full-time
real estate investors to people
who real estate as a hobby.
I do real estate
investment as a hobby.
So by using that website, I
was able to educate myself
and eventually find that
first investment property.
So we're lucky to
have Josh Dorkin, who
is the CEO of BiggerPockets.
And we also have Brandon Turner,
who is the VP of marketing.
They're going to come
down here and tell
you guys about real estate and
how you guys can get involved
in it while working
a full-time job.
So let's hear it for
Brandon and Josh.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH: Thank you, Jordan.
Another BiggerPockets
success story, right there.
All right, so as Jordan
introduced, my name is Josh.
I am the founder
BiggerPockets.com.
And really quickly, as
Jordan was talking about,
he was out there
looking for information,
and he kept coming across
these kind of shady characters
who dominated the space.
So when I started almost 10
years ago as a real estate
investor, I was dealing
with the exact same thing.
I'm a New Yorker,
and as I like to say,
my BS-o-meter is
pretty finely attuned.
And when I came across these
guys I said, this is crazy.
There's got to be another
way to get information.
And so I set out to kind
of democratize real estate
investing information,
because I was in need of it,
and I realized that other
people would be as well.
So that is the birth
of BiggerPockets.
But we're not here to teach you
to be real estate investors.
You're not going to learn
how to become a real estate
investor today.
You're not going to go
out tomorrow and get
rich from anything that we say.
But hopefully we give you
guys some fundamentals,
some basics, that
will help you maybe
get a better understanding
of what's out there,
and hopefully will point you
to some tools and possibilities
that will get you on your way.
So that's me.
And next to me is
the big guy, clearly.
He's quite large.
And this is Brandon Turner.
BRANDON: Hello, everyone.
Yeah my name is
Brandon, as he said,
and Jordan said, and I just
want to say again, thank you,
Jordan, for having us out here.
So I started in real estate
investing at 21 years old.
I'm 28 right now.
Bought my first property at 21.
I live in an area that's a lot
cheaper than you guys live in
up here.
So I was able to buy
probably more properties
faster than a lot of people can.
So by the time I was 25, I was
able to quit my job and retire,
so to speak, as much
as you can retire
when you own a lot
of rental property.
I quickly figured
out that that wasn't
very fun to be "retired."
So I ended up starting a blog,
helping out Josh Dorkin here,
and ended up coming on board.
So that's how I got here.
I started real estate
investing in a similar way,
as I didn't know
what I was doing.
I wanted to be in real estate.
I wanted to get involved.
I called up my dad and
I said, "All right, Dad!
I know what I'm gonna
do for a living now!
I'm gonna be a real
estate investor!"
And he said, "You're an idiot."
Essentially was
the word he said.
He said you're
gonna go homeless,
you're gonna go
broke, your tenants
are not going to pay rent, and
you're gonna lose everything."
So I'm like crap,
like, that's, what's
going to happen to my life.
You're right.
All right.
Well, I'll go back
to law school,
or go work at
Google or something.
So I decided instead--
I went online
and I typed in "what to do
when tenants don't pay rent."
And what I discovered was, first
of all, BiggerPockets that's
how I first found them, and
what I discovered was-- they
were were a community of people.
There's real estate
investors out there
who like to share
what they know.
And that's exactly
what we're about today.
We want to share what we've
learned, mistakes we've made,
and what we've done right,
kind of help each other out
so you don't have to
pay money to do that.
So with that, why don't we get
started talking about the seven
steps to get
started in investing
real estate-- with
jokes, hopefully.
So feel free-- we want to
have a good time doing this,
so pretend to laugh--
even if we're not funny.
See?
All right.
All right, first of all,
before we get into it,
let's talk about why
real estate investing.
I'm going to start out just by
talking about diversification.
It's a big word.
Basically it means we don't want
all of our eggs in one basket.
A lot of you guys probably
have stocks or whatever.
If you have all your
stuff in one basket,
you're setting yourself
up for a lot greater risk.
JOSH: All right, so
we've got control.
One of the nice things
about real estate
is you actually
have more control
than with a stock or a
bond or things like that.
The stock you're
buying, you're hoping
that the CEO of the company
is doing the right thing,
the employees are
doing their jobs,
and everything's
going to go well.
In terms of real
estate, you can actually
control a lot of what happens.
So you can manage
purchase price,
you can manage the
maintenance, you
can manage who you put in there.
So having that control gives
you a little more power
over your investment.
BRANDON: All right, leverage.
How many of you guys went
to summer camp as a kid?
Nobody at summer camp?
OK, a few people.
All right, so one of my
memories of summer camp
was the teeter-totter,
or do you say see-saw?
JOSH: See-saw.
It's a see-saw.
BRANDON: Well, whatever.
Teeter-totter, see-saw,
you know the thing, right?
Or, for the science
people, we're
talking about, like, a
fulcrum-- is that the word?
Right, so leverage is the
idea of moving large objects
with small amount.
I remember I was like-- I
was the big fat kid at camp.
And so you could,
depending on where
you sat on the teeter-totter,
you could move large objects.
So that's the idea with
real estate investing.
With a small amount
of money you can
move a large amount
of property, which
is one of my favorite
things about it.
JOSH: All right.
And of course the most important
thing is financial freedom.
We're all here.
We're working we're doing
these things to support
our friends, our families,
well, hopefully you're
not supporting your
friends, but you're
supporting your families.
And the ultimate end-all
be-all American Dream
is financial freedom, right?
So real estate is
definitely another means
to an end to get there.
You may end up getting to a
point with your real estate
career where Google doesn't
work for you anymore,
and you're working for yourself.
I don't know that the big
guy wants to hear that,
but that might happen.
And that's, again, that's
the goal, because in the end
you're going to take
that money and you're
going to do what with it?
You're going to give
it to your family,
and you're going to do all
the things are looking for.
So real estate
investing, we get into it
because ultimately we're
trying to have a better
life for ourselves
and our families.
BRANDON: All right,
let's get started.
If you guys are writing
this down or taking notes
on your computer, I'm just
going to go through--- well,
we're going to go
through all seven steps.
So step number one is
it to get educated.
Now when a lot of people
think of getting educated,
just as Jordan said
earlier, they think of this.
So.
Oh!
There it is!
All right.
So, we got the
snake oil salesmen
who's always advertising
how you can get rich.
You can get the
girl in the bikini,
and you can get the
red convertible.
For some reason
those three things
always go together on the
late night TV infomercials.
That's not what we're
talking about today.
So try to get that out
of your mind, please.
JOSH: All right.
There are other ways to go.
You don't have to
spend-- ultimately,
what these guys do is there's
this kind of dominance
over the information space that
they've kind of projected out
there.
You hear it on the commercials,
you see it at these seminars.
They have these funnels
where, come to this free event
and you're going to learn all
about real estate investing.
Well these free events
are really lead funnels
to get you to spend $997,
to get you to spend $19,000,
to get you to spend $50,000.
The next thing you
know you've given them
all your money and
you've got nothing.
There are other ways you can go.
You've got books, you've
got blogs, mentors, forums,
podcasts, YouTube.
There is enough information out
on the web, as you guys know
who own the web, that
you can pretty much learn
the entire business online,
or at the library, things
like that.
But you don't have to
depend on these guys.
Ultimately, with
education, the key
is you want to know what
you're getting into here, OK?
If you go.
I'll give an example of myself.
I started real estate investing.
I was a smart guy--
not quite a Googler,
but I was fairly intelligent.
And I thought I could do it all.
Somebody, my brother
said to me, hey, Josh,
you should buy some real estate.
I said, great.
I went, I bought some real
estate not knowing anything.
So I'm like I'm smart
enough to figure it out.
Well, very quickly realized
I was not smart enough
to figure it out on my own.
I ended up, over a period of
time, losing about $100,000
off of the first investments
that I got involved in.
It was because I didn't
have the education.
I didn't have the
full understanding
of what I needed to do.
And again, that
kind of goes back
to the origins of this
website, BiggerPockets,
was because ultimately
I needed the answers.
I needed a place to go.
The nice thing
about the mentors,
and a nice thing about
groups like our site,
or other groups,
clubs, things like that
where you can get
educated, is you
can count on the support of
other people to help you out.
And it really is
important in real estate
to have that support net
to help you get going.
BRANDON: Right you are.
Step number two is to choose
your niche and your strategy.
This is the way that
I like to explain it,
because real estate investing
can be really overwhelming
because it's so broad.
Let me explain what
I mean by that.
First of all, there's
niches and there's
strategies when
you're investing.
Oh!
We're not up there anymore.
Well, all right,
well I'll just talk.
Basically there are niches and
there are strategies, right?
So niches would be like
the actual property
types you're buying.
For example, you got single
family, multi-family,
commercial, notes, raw
land, anything like that.
It's actually like
property types.
On the other side
of the equation,
you have different
strategies that you can use.
So, for example, you might
want to flip a house.
So you guys ever seen
the flipping shows?
How many of you have
seen flipping shows?
The TV-- yeah, all right.
So that's a strategy, not
necessarily-- another strategy
would be buy and hold.
That's where you buy
something hold onto it.
Other could be live-in
investments, things like that,
that you hold onto while
you're living inside of it.
For example, if you
live in a duplex,
you live in half of it,
that's also strategy.
So the problem with
real estate investing
is that it gets really,
really overwhelming for a lot
of people, because they
see all this stuff,
and all these
people say, no, you
should do this and
this and this and this.
What we recommend is just
choose one niche and just
choose one strategy.
So for example, you might want
to flip single family houses.
Great.
So learn about flipping
single family houses.
You might want to buy and
hold commercial properties.
That's OK, too.
You might want to do a
live-in multi-family property.
So you don't need
to know everything
in the world to get
started in real estate.
Just pick one thing, get
good at that one thing,
and then move on from there.
So with that, we're gonna
move onto the next slide here.
All right.
So we're going to have
a jobs person investing.
I'll let Josh take that one.
JOSH: Sure.
All right, I'll talk about
active versus passive.
So with real estate, there's
really two ways to go.
You can say hey, I'm going to be
an active real estate investor,
or I'm going to be a passive
real estate investor.
House-flipping shows that
Brandon had talked about,
you're an active
real estate investor.
You're out there.
You're finding the property.
You're picking the color.
You're dealing with
the contractors,
dealing with the headaches.
It's a job.
Don't let anyone
tell you otherwise.
Flipping houses is a job.
Passive is really, it's
more like-- passive
is where-- it's
what it says, right?
Passive is like buying
a stock essentially,
but a little bit more work.
You purchase, you sit
back, and you kind of
wait for things to happen.
In passive-- for
example, buy and hold--
you're going to be depending
upon a property manager who's
going to watch the property
and do most of the work.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about that later on.
But ultimately, there is
not one right way to invest,
as Brandon had said earlier.
However, we definitely
recommend that you
choose that one niche
and that one strategy.
It may not be the right one,
but pick one and go with it,
because if you're worried about
every other strategy that's
out there, or every other
niche that's out there,
you're going to get
really, it's going
to cause you to kind
of get confused,
and ultimately in the end,
people will never act.
That's one of the
biggest things that we
see with new real
estate investors is
they fail to act because there's
just so much information out
there, and they don't
really know where to go.
Which leads us to the
development of your plan.
BRANDON: All right.
So number three-- we talked
about number one and two.
Number three is going
to be to develop
your plan I like to
explain it like this.
I'm from the Seattle area.
I would not generally
get in my car
and go and drive 3,500 miles
to Mexico City just knowing
that it's south, right?
Anybody work on the Google
Maps department here?
I don't know if
you guys do that?
So, thankfully, we have maps,
things like Google Maps,
that we can get our car
and drive and follow
somebody who's already done it.
So that's what
developing your plan is.
It's about getting
a starting point
and ending point and knowing
where you're ending up at.
So we're going to explain just
a couple sample plans, because I
don't like to be
always theoretical.
Let's get actually
realistic here.
So first plan I
want to talk about
is buying single family houses.
Again these are just samples,
so bear with me on this example.
You might buy single
family houses,
and you might say,
OK, well, I want
to buy a single
family house that
provides $200 per month
in passive cash flow.
So every month I have $200
left over after all the bills,
including property management,
whatever I paid for.
I want $200 left.
And I only want to
put down $20,000.
OK, so that's the
beginning of our plan.
Then you're going
to say, well, I'm
going to buy one
property in year one.
I need the math people here
to listen closely here.
One in year one, two in year
two, three in year three,
and so on, all the
way up to year 10.
Any geniuses in here know
how many, after year ten,
how many you'd have?
Anybody?
55!
Smart guy there!
All right, so you've got
55 houses and 11 hundred
per month--
JOSH: Thousand.
BRANDON: $11,000 per month
in passive cash flow.
Which gives you a nice, in
10 years, a nice addition.
And that's building
real slowly, right?
Just one in year
one, two in year two.
It's all about a plan, right?
So that's just one sample
plan you might look into.
JOSH: Another
sample plan might be
to start with small,
multi-family properties that
provide a 15% return
on investment.
Again, buy one
property per year.
So, say you start with
a duplex, for example.
Maybe you decide, you know what?
I'm going to live
in half the duplex.
I want to get the experience to
manage my tenants, my toilets,
and all the headaches
that come with it,
but I want to see
and feel that, right?
So I get in there, I buy this
duplex, I live in half of it,
pretty much have my mortgage
paid for by the other folks who
are living on the property.
And then, after a year
or two, I decide OK, I'm
going to move up to a fourplex.
And so I buy a fourplex
and then I move up,
and so on and so forth.
So you save all the cash flow
for future down payments.
You trade up to
larger unit numbers
as more income comes
in, and in time you
buy the 30 unit, the 50
unit, if you are so inclined
to continue going.
Or you just stop where
you need to stop.
Ultimately you want to set what
your expectations are up front.
You want to really
look at where are you,
where are you in life, what's
your end-all, be-all goal.
Do you want to be a full-time
real estate investor?
Do you want to be part time?
Do you just need
enough to get by?
We're doing pretty good now.
We just want to make a couple
of thousand bucks a month extra.
Well, reverse
engineer it, right?
Think about how
much you need, build
a plan that builds that
into it, and figure out
how do you get there.
BRANDON: All right.
So step number four in the
plan that we're talking about
is finding your property.
Because we already talked
about the education
we already talked about
picking what you want to do.
Next we want to talk about
finding which property.
And there's a lot of different
ways you can do that.
We're just going to run
through them real quickly, just
some of the common techniques.
First of all, there is the MLS.
If you've ever bought
or sold a house,
chances are you bought
and sold one off the MLS,
meaning a real estate
agent listed it
and you went and bought it.
In a competitive
market-- especially
the competitive market
around here I've heard
is ridiculous--
it's very, very hard
to find good deals on there,
but they can be found.
JOSH: Then you've
got networking.
So networking,
you've got events.
You've got, I mean,
you guys have a campus.
This is college campus right?
Google Campus, right?
I mean Jordan's an investor.
There's 30 people in here.
Why don't you guys start
a real estate club?
The Google Real Estate
Club would be a great idea.
You guys can work
together, network.
You guys can find deals
together, work on projects,
finance things like that.
Networking is an amazing way
to build up your investments
in your base.
And just a real
quick plug-- tonight
we're actually doing a meet-up
in San Francisco of real estate
investors in town.
If any of you guys want to
come, you're welcome to join us.
Jordan's got the information.
But there's like a
hundred something people
who are getting together
to talk about real estate.
No pitchiness.
It's just people hanging out
and trying to figure it out.
BRANDON: Another way that
a lot of investors use
is marketing to find good deals.
This gets a little
more advanced,
and I'm not suggesting everyone
goes out and does right away.
But by marketing,
meaning anything
from billboards to an ad in
newspaper, an ad on Craigslist,
Google AdWords-- I've
used that to find deals.
Anything like that is marketing.
It's going on the offensive,
and go and get a good deal
instead of just waiting
for it to come to you.
JOSH: Then, if you're looking
for commercial properties,
you've got sites like
LoopNet, CoStar-- you guys
might want to write these down.
There's these portals where
you can go out and find
the listings for the
commercial properties.
You may not find the
best deals, but if you
start searching, start
looking at these properties
and these platforms,
you could at least
start to see what
the numbers are.
You guys are all mostly number
crunchers, I'm guessing.
So you can figure out
kind of what works,
what doesn't work by starting
to experience what's out there.
BRANDON: All right,
and finally I
just want to throw out
there, BiggerPockets
which is where we
spend our time.
People come on there
and sell, give away,
trade, whatever deals.
Moving on, next one, number five
is to pay for your investment.
It's not free.
I mean, there's no such
thing as a free lunch--
unless you work at Google.
There you go!
All right!
JOSH: First laugh!
Yeah!
First laugh!
BRANDON: Give that man a drink!
All right.
So you've got to pay
for your investment.
The best way-- I mean there's
a lot of different ways--
I'm not going to
say the best way.
But we're going to run through
probably, I don't know,
six or seven of them real quick.
First of all number one
probably, maybe most common way
to pay for an
investment is all cash.
If you are rich or if you're
investing in a cheap area,
you can write a nice big check,
great, cash is always good.
People-- sellers love cash.
So if you can offer
cash, that's great.
But it's not feasible.
I've never done it.
So let's move on.
JOSH: Well, and the advantage
really quick of cash
is that a seller's
going to look at you
and say, all right, this
guy can close quickly right?
So it's you versus the guy
who's getting the financing--
conventional loans for example.
You've got cash,
you come up, they
know that you don't have
to wait for the bank
to approve the loan.
They know that you
can walk in and take
this property off their hands.
So they're more
likely than not going
to lean towards your offer,
even if it's potentially even
less, because it's
more secure offer.
Conventional loans
are pretty much what
you guys have probably
all bought your properties
if you own house.
A conventional loan, your
Wells Fargo, your Citibank,
things like that.
And conventional, you're
putting down 20% up
to potentially 30%
on your property,
and they're going
to finance the rest.
So that's a conventional loan.
BRANDON: All right, next I want
to talk about government loans.
How many of you guys
actually own your own home?
Can I ask that?
Quite a few people.
Did anybody use an FHA
loan when they did it?
All right, so let me explain.
FHA-- there's also VA
and USDA-- we're not
going to do that-- FHA is a
loan program the government has
which insures your loan, which
means you can get a cheaper
down payment.
Right now it's at 3.5%.
So if you're buying a $100,000
property, which, I know,
is cheap, but if you were buying
$100,000 for easy numbers,
$3,500 is what you
would need down.
Now granted, you have to
live in that property--
I think it's for a year.
But it could be a duplex,
triplex, or fourplex.
My favorite strategy in all
of real estate investing
is to find a multi-family
property like that,
live in one of the units,
rent the other ones out.
Move out later.
And you've got that
nice fixed rate,
low down payment multi-family
property that just provides
cash flow for the
rest of your life.
I did that actually with
a duplex that I bought.
Ended it up,
interesting, it ended up
that duplex we found
out years later
was Kurt Cobain's very first
house, which is interesting.
We found out because
some Swedish tourists
were knocking on the door trying
to take pictures of the inside.
Yeah.
Fun side story.
JOSH: And now he owns two
of Kurt Cobain's houses.
It's true.
If anyone wants one,
any Nirvana fans?
Does anyone like Nirvana?
There's an investment
house for sale.
Anyone?
Bueller?
All right.
Portfolio loans.
Portfolio loans
are loans that are
owned by the lender themselves.
So you guys remember the
housing crisis where everybody's
talking about slicing and
dicing loans and selling them
and things like that.
Portfolio loans are where a
banking, a lending institution,
is going to own the loan.
They're not going
to sell it off.
The nice thing about
portfolio lenders
are they love
investors, and they're
pretty easy to work
with, generally.
If you've got good
deals, they want them.
So they're going to
want to work with you.
They're not gonna-- especially
if you start to learn how
to deal with lenders, and
you can present yourself
in a professional way, and give
them your loan package and say,
hey, here's a property,
here's all the details,
and you do well by it,
they're going to love you.
They're going to want
you to keep coming back.
And portfolio lenders are
definitely a preferred source
of money for most
sophisticated investors.
BRANDON: All right.
The next type of loan
that's pretty popular
is a commercial loan.
If you're gonna buy a property
like a large multi-family
five units and up,
or if you're going
to buy an office building,
trailer park, whatever,
you're going to want to
use a commercial loan.
They're very similar to
portfolio in that any bank can
generally do a commercial loan.
They usually require a little
bit higher down payment-- maybe
25%, 30%.
But it can finance--
I mean, if you can--
Here's a cool example of
something you could do.
Let's say you get 10 guys
together, all throw in $50,000.
You've got $500,000.
You go to a bank and
get a commercial loan
on a $10 million property.
Use the 10 guys you
gathered together
as a down payment on the
commercial loan and the rest.
There's a lot of
fun games you can
play with that when
you go commercial.
So if you guys decide
to go commercial,
yeah, look into that and find
a good commercial lender.
JOSH: And find a good
real estate attorney.
Don't just like, hey, we're
going to throw money together
and we're gonna do this!
Like you want to, again,
about the education.
I know Brandon uses it,
and it's a good example,
but truth be told, don't
go out there and do stuff
unless you've made
sure that it's legit
and it's kosher, because there's
a lot of bad information--
I'm not saying his
information is bad--
but there's a lot of bad
information out there,
and you really do have
to be careful of that.
So I really do recommend--
and we don't talk about team
at all on this, but part
of your investing team
absolutely should be a
real estate attorney.
It's one most important people.
[RANDOM AUDIO OUTBURST]
JOSH: And thank you very much.
All right so we've got
hard money lenders.
Hard money lenders are
kind of the loan sharks.
A lot of people think--
if you hear of them
and they think
loan sharks, right?
These are guys who actually
loan money for short term--
and it's pretty expensive.
They're going to-- you're
going to pay points on it.
You might be paying 12%,
15% on a hard money loan.
But it's going to be a
loan for six months, nine
months, something like that.
This is one of the preferred
loans for flippers.
House flippers love
hard money loans,
because they're generally,
the hard-money lenders
have an understanding of
what flippers are doing.
They can look at
a property and say
this is going to be a good deal.
You're going to be
able turn it over fast.
You have the resources.
I'm going to give you the
money, make my money fast,
and we're all going to be happy.
Hard money loans.
BRANDON: All right,
we're almost done
with the different
financing things.
But there's also
private money, which
would be things like
family, or friends.
If you borrow money from
somebody that you know,
dangerous to do that.
Not necessarily that
you know like well,
but if you borrow money from
people that you might network
with, that's called
private money.
Usually a little bit cheaper.
For example,
there's a guy I know
in Portland who just lent
me $100,000 to go buy
an investment property and
then I'm gonna refinance it.
Worked out really great for me,
it worked out great for him,
and that's a perfect
private money deal.
So I recommend looking into that
if you're looking for financing
and can't get it from a bank.
JOSH: So that was private money.
Partners-- and on
private money, you
want to be really
sure the person you're
working with-- you
are in bed with them.
So make sure you're
comfortable with the folks
that you're doing that.
The same goes for partners.
So partners would be, you know,
you and your buddy say hey,
we want to get into the game.
I'm going to put up
50%, and you put up 50%,
and let's get in
this deal together.
Or he may put up all the
money, you may do all the work,
things like that.
But if you work with folks, you
can come up with creative ways
to potentially even do
deals with no cash out
of your own pocket.
But again, you want to make sure
you're very careful with who
you're working with
which leads us to--
BRANDON: All right.
The last one I want to
talk about real quick
is just seller financing.
What seller financing is
is when you buy a property
from the person who owns
it, and they actually
carry the mortgage.
So instead of you paying
a bank every month,
you pay the seller every month.
That's actually how I bought
my 24 unit apartment building.
There was an older couple
who went to my church.
I mentioned one
day, hey, you know,
I'd love to buy an
apartment building.
And they said, huh, interesting.
We actually have one.
And it worked out perfect.
That's that networking thing
we talked about earlier.
Well, what we ended
up doing is they
ended up carrying
the contract on it,
which is they
carried the mortgage.
I pay them every month.
They're this cute old
couple who drive around
the country in their
motor home now.
And like, that's their
entire retirement
is what I pay them every month.
It works out amazing for them.
Worked out great for me.
And it's a really,
really great way
to buy real estate
if you can do it.
JOSH: It's like an annuity.
BRANDON: Yeah, yeah
it's really nice.
With that, let's move
on to step number six.
JOSH: All right.
Step number six--
self management
versus property management.
We're not really talking about
flipping houses here, now.
We're talking about
investment properties,
buy and hold things--
buy and hold properties.
So self managing
is pretty obvious.
You buy a property, you're
taking care of the toilets,
you're taking care
of the tenants,
of the maintenance,
you're taking care
of the headaches,
and yes, you will
deal with all of that.
Self managing is-- it
can be very challenging.
It could be very fulfilling.
In the end, it could
be very time-consuming.
That said, if you're
going to become a landlord
and end up having
somebody outside do it
for you, definitely, definitely
recommend self managing
first versus
property management.
Property management, you're
gonna hire a company,
they're going to take
care of the property.
Now that said, when I told
you that I had a hard time
and lost a lot of money.
Well, I did that
primarily because I
hired the wrong
property management.
I went out there.
I didn't know what
I was looking for.
I didn't know what to do.
So I went and I hired
a property manager.
All right, great!
Property manager screwed me.
Hired another property manager.
Hired another one.
And it was this dirty
trail of tears for me.
And ultimately-- so you have
to know, a passive investment,
you're not necessarily-- when
you've got these property
managers, you want to
know how to screen them.
You want to know
what to look for.
And you want to make sure
they're doing their job.
So there is the active part
of the passive investment.
But in the end, again,
professional property managers
are going to do the job.
They're going to take
care of the asset.
And they may even help
you find additional deals.
BRANDON: All right.
Step number seven.
We're going to close this
thing up here in a minute.
And that is planning
your exit strategy.
We talked about, earlier,
the map, driving from Seattle
all the way down to Mexico City.
You have to know
where Mexico City's at
in order to get there.
So you have to know where
your destination is.
You may change throughout your
life where that destination is,
but it's still important
to kind of plan for that.
So we're going to
talk about just a few
of the more common
exit strategies
a person might have in
their investment career.
So the first one would be
holding onto a property
forever.
What I mean by that is
indefinitely, right?
So you might buy a bunch
of rental properties
with no real plan
to get rid of them.
And that's probably OK, as long
as you do your asset protection
well, so when you
die your kids will
get the property correctly.
So there are people
who do hold forever,
and that is a valid
exit strategy.
JOSH: Sell it and cash out.
So you buy a property.
You sell it.
Maybe you're flipping house.
So you buy it, short term.
You sell it.
Flip it.
Get another property.
Sell it.
Flip it.
Keep going, keep
going, keep going.
Again, that's a
really active activity
that you're going to be doing.
But if you buy these properties
at a good value, good price,
you can potentially make
a lot of money doing this.
Again, you have to
be educated to know
how to buy the properties,
what a good price is,
how to evaluate it.
That education
component comes in
to make sure that you
don't make a mistake.
With real estate
investments, you really
make your money on the purchase.
So don't think, hey,
I'm going to make money
because there's going
be appreciation.
If you are buying, betting on
appreciation, you're gambling.
You might as well be the
casino and throw all your money
on black.
If you want to actually
purchase and be smart about it,
you're going to
analyze the deal,
you're going to analyze
the fundamentals, the area,
everything that's going
on, and you're not
going to bet on appreciation.
Think of appreciation
as a bonus.
BRANDON: All right,
another strategy ties
into what I talked about
earlier, and that's
a lot of investors choose
to sell via seller financing
eventually.
So you get old and tired
of doing real estate.
You decide to sell
all your properties
to another investor who's then
going to take care of them,
just like the older
couple did for me.
It can work out
really well, and it
can carry you 20, 30
years into retirement.
JOSH: And keep trading-up.
I think we had talked
about that earlier
with the multi-family plan.
You buy the multi-family,
you hold onto it
for a couple years.
Collect the cash flow.
You're paying down
these mortgages.
You sell that thing.
Trade up to the next one.
There's things that are
called 1031 exchanges.
You can actually defer
taxes on the purchase
of the next property.
So trading-up is a
pretty good strategy.
I think it's one of the
more preferred strategies
of the longer-term
real estate investors.
And it's a great way to go.
BRANDON: All right.
Well, we're just going
to wrap it up now,
and we're going to open
up for some questions.
But first of all, if you
guys want to learn more,
we talked about it earlier,
don't pay tens of thousands,
or hundreds of thousands
of dollars to learn.
And like I said, focus on the
books, the blogs, the mentors,
the forums, podcasts,
things like YouTube.
And there is so much free
information out there.
Information has been
democratized in the real estate
investing world-- I mean in
any world, but especially
real estate.
There's so much information
out there for free or for cheap
that I can't recommend that
enough, is don't throw away
hundreds of thousands
of dollars on education.
If you guys want to know more
exactly what we talked about
today, we are the co-authors
of a book called "The Ultimate
Beginner's Guide to
Real Estate Investing."
It is free, which is helpful.
It's online.
It's at biggerpockets.com/UBG
And with that,
we're just going to
open up for questions.
So if anybody has any questions
at all, we're open books, so.
AUDIENCE: Uh, two questions.
First of all, is the slide deck
that you didn't show available
on the site?
BRANDON: It can be, yes,
I can put it up there.
JOSH: Yeah, we can put this up.
MALE SPEAKER: Can you
repeat the question?
BRANDON: Sure.
The question was, is the slide--
is the slide deck going to be--
can we put it up on the site?
Yeah, we can.
And I can get copies.
Basically, the slide deck
was just simple two words
of what we had read
out loud, I guess, just
to kind of keep
focus, but yeah we
can throw that out there, too.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question.
Many years ago I read
this guy Kiyosaki.
Which category do
you put him in?
BRANDON: Oh, like
Robert Kiyosaki?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
"Poor Dad, Rich Dad."
BRANDON: Yeah, he wrote
"Rich Dad, Poor Dad, "
which was probably the
most foundational--
he was asking about Robert
Kiyosaki, where I put him.
I mean "Rich Dad, Poor
Dad," I would say,
is the number one
most foundational book
that most real estate
investors read.
I recommend reading the book.
Rich Dad organization
has a lot more stuff.
You can analyze that,
figure out if it's something
you want to do.
It can be very expensive.
But "Rich Dad, Poor
Dad," the book, I'd
say if you're going to read
one book, start with that one.
JOSH: It's a good motivator.
BRANDON: It's a
very good motivator.
JOSH: It's one of those books
that you're gonna open up--
BRANDON: It's not a how-to
book, but it's a good motivator.
AUDIENCE: What's the slash URL?
JOSH: UBG.
UBG.
BRANDON: Yeah.
Ultimate Beginner's Guide.
AUDIENCE: I have a
couple of questions.
What are your thoughts on
short-term furnished rentals--
BRANDON: Short-term
furnished rentals?
AUDIENCE: Short-term
furnished rentals [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH: Talking like
Airbnb, VRBO stuff.
AUDIENCE: And my other
question is, do you
recommend getting a
Realtor [INAUDIBLE]?
BRANDON: Good questions.
All right.
So his questions
were, first of all,
what do you think about
short-term rentals,
like vacation rentals,
Airbnb, or VRBO, those sites.
The second question--
well, I'll get to that.
So the first one is,
I don't personally
have a need for them.
I think they're a
good idea potentially,
but I think a lot of people get
emotion involved when you're
doing it, because
you're like, oh,
I could buy a house
in Puerto Vallarta,
and it's going to be amazing!
I could rent it
out all year round!
It's very, very expensive to
manage that kind of thing.
So especially local, I mean,
I would love to buy something
in my area that was local
that people could rent,
because there can be a
lot of money in that.
A second half of
that, though, is
if you guys looked at
the paper the other day,
it was on the
front page of paper
was landlords are now
being sued because they're
breaking the law.
In a lot of areas
you can't actually
have short-term
vacation rentals.
And in the past
it's kind of been,
the government has kind
of turned the other way
and not really cared.
But now they're starting
to go after landlords
who are doing this.
JOSH: Yeah, like in New
York they're actually,
I think it's the AG is
suing Airbnb to get access--
to get access to
the land-- the folks
who are renting their
properties out via Airbnb,
because the hotel lobby's not
happy about that business.
I know San Francisco, I think,
is also not happy about it.
So I think with
vacation rentals,
a lot of people-- we
know folks, plenty
of folks who are
making very good money.
In fact I know a person who
was a long-term landlord who
basically waited till leases
were up, got his tenants out
and used-- transformed his
property to short-term rentals.
And the amount of
money he's making
is considerably more
with short-term rentals.
But you really have to focus.
There's a lot of
energy to put it in.
Your second question was--
BRANDON: Real estate agent.
JOSH: Oh, real estate agent.
You know, it's interesting.
That's one of the
biggest debates
that we see on our
site, on BiggerPockets.
I think the negative
to it is that you're
beholding to follow
the rules, so to speak.
I don't see that as a negative.
The best thing about
a real estate license
is you have access to the MLS.
You have access to
deals as they come up.
You can write contracts,
and presumably you're
educated about what
needs to be done
on the transactional
side of things.
So everybody that-- we do
a podcast, and everybody
that we've interviewed on the
podcast who has a real estate
license has said it's
absolutely worth doing.
Think about it.
If you're a house
flipper, you pay,
you pay-- you don't pay
anything on the purchase,
but on the sale you got to pay
the 6%, or 8%, approximately.
So you're paying 6% in
commissions every time
you do it, over and over again.
Well if you're the agent,
you're collecting at least half
of that, right?
So you're saving a lot
of money in the long term
by being a real estate
agent and, again, you
have quicker access to
deals as they come up--
at least on the MLS.
BRANDON: And I do not have
my real estate license.
And I've taken the
class to do it,
and then when it
came down to it,
I decided, personally, I
decided I didn't want to do it.
I don't really know why.
I mean it was a couple
thousand a year at the time,
and I thought, well, I'm
not really buying that much.
When I look back, I regret
not doing it at the time.
And now I could
go back and do it,
but it's another
hundred hours of work.
So I probably will do it.
And I guess if I had to say,
yes, I do recommend getting it
even though I don't have it.
So do what I say, not what
I do Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: There's
a question on DC.
BRANDON: Oh, cool.
AUDIENCE: Uh, so, [INAUDIBLE].
But with democratization
of information,
like, why are there deals
still to be had, right?
So the back of my mind says
that [INAUDIBLE] a lot of money?
[INAUDIBLE]
Why is it still possible to do?
Why isn't [INAUDIBLE]?
Does that make sense?
JOSH: Yeah.
So how many people do we have
here in the United States?
What?
330 million?
I mean, people die.
People go bankrupt.
People have divorces.
People have
situations where they
are in a distressed
situation, right?
You may get hired by an
investment bank in New York,
and you've got to
get up and move,
get up and move fast.
So what do you?
You've gotta dump it, you've
gotta unload your property,
you gotta get out.
So in the end, if
that ever stops,
then the deals will stop.
But it's never going to happen.
AUDIENCE: But why
hasn't the number
of investors risen to
meet that demand, right?
[INAUDIBLE] dropped to pick
up those hundred dollar
bills lying on the sidewalk.
JOSH: I think you're
gonna got me started
on a political discussion
about our education system.
And that's going to be
a really bad discussion.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
And the second question-- where
does the name BiggerPockets
come from?
JOSH: Where did the name
BiggerPockets come from?
Good question!
So BiggerPockets came
from-- here we go.
I used to be in the
entertainment business.
BiggerPockets, the name,
was actually originally
born out of that.
I have a buddy who was in
this really cheesy indie film,
and he played this drug dealer.
And he's sitting there
with this drink in one hand
and a wad of cash
that he's trying
to get out of his pocket.
And he's just struggling
and struggling,
and he finally gets it
out, and he's like, "Man,
I gotta get bigger pockets!"
And I was like, brilliant!
That name is amazing.
I can do anything with that.
I can build a real estate site,
I could build any kind of site,
because it could kind of
talk about really anything.
So that's pretty much
where it came from.
AUDIENCE: You had mentioned
that for commercial real estate,
one strategy is to get 10 people
together and buy [INAUDIBLE].
Are there smart ways of doing
that for smaller properties?
So, for example, if I want
to buy a million dollar home,
but I only have a
hundred thousand,
are there resources where I
can find nine other people?
I don't have nine friends or
nine people who I can trust.
Are there safe ways to kind of
go in on real estate that way?
BRANDON: Sure.
I mean, there's a
few ways to do it.
One of, I think, the best
ways that we talked about
is networking, right?
So if you go to a
real estate club,
every major city has
real estate clubs,
and some you have to be really
careful about, because all
they are is just pitch-fest,
and buy this product.
But if you can find a
good-- even at the bad ones,
I mean if you can
find people who
are interested in
doing deals together,
they're all one mind, right?
We want to buy deals together.
So that's a good way.
There is crowdfunding.
It's kind of a new, it's
been coming out lately.
It's like Kickstarter,
right, but for real estate
investments.
People pool their money-- you
don't even know who they are,
just lots of people are
throwing their money in.
That's kind of a new-- exciting
new twist on the real estate
investment world.
And we didn't really get a
chance to talk about a lot
today, because personally I've
never invested in one of them.
But that is a way
to do it as well.
I would never go and
put up an advertisement
in the newspaper that says, hey,
I'm looking for five partners
to go and buy a property.
That just seems like
you're calling down
trouble from the
government on-- there's
a lot of interesting
laws and stuff
you have to deal when you
get into that so I wouldn't
publicly do it.
JOSH: So, really quick
to extend on that.
So the SEC.
The SEC is, has--
MALE SPEAKER: Microphone!
JOSH: Oh, sorry.
Thank you.
Sorry.
So the SEC has a lot
of rules about what
you can do with raising money
for-- whether it be a company
or for real estate, public
offerings, things like that.
I'm not going to even try
and explain any of it.
I'm not a lawyer.
Don't pretend to be.
But when you go in and
bring people together,
you really need your
real estate attorney
to make sure that
you're doing it kosher.
If it's you and your brother,
and your five closest
friends, fine.
But once you start kind of
dealing with people that
are outside of your-- even
people in your circle--
you want to talk to a
lawyer and structure it,
because there's a lot of
intricacies with the law.
So you want to make sure
you're doing it the right way.
And on the crowdfunding
thing, really quickly.
So a lot of these sites have
come out of the JOBS Act, where
funding is kind of-- I guess
the SEC's kind of loosened
up about what's allowed.
But it's not like
Kickstarter, right?
Kickstarter, you go and
you're donating cash, right?
You're donating
money for a project,
and you get a prize in
return for that donation.
With crowdfunding,
you're actually
investing in the property.
So the government is
pretty hardcore in their--
this is a very nascent
way to finance property.
And so, personally, I would
not get into a deal that way.
I want to watch and
see what's going
to happen before I
would jump into that.
So, anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Was
wondering if you could
say a bit more about property
management [INAUDIBLE]
what to watch out for, what
can go wrong, [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH: All right, so the question
was on property management,
how to find them,
what to look for.
This is not a shameless
plug, but we-- years ago,
when I was dealing with all
the chaos of my own property
management, I put together
a list of questions.
And it was, I don't
remember them now
off the top of my
head, but we can
find a way to get
it to you guys.
But ultimately,
you want to know do
you want a property manager who
manages their own properties?
Are they competing?
Are they going to take
tenants and put their tenants
in their own properties
before they put them
in your properties.
So you want to interview them.
What's their style?
What they do with
tenant screening?
How careful are they
in looking for tenants?
What's their policy
on late rents?
on contractors?
How do they manage
broken toilets?
You need to-- there's
a thousand questions
that we can go through.
Ultimately, the key is not
just picking the first property
manager that's out there.
You literally want
to go out there.
And the same goes for real
estate agents, and pretty
much anybody else that you're
dealing with in real estate.
You want to interview
multiple people,
and you want to find out
what their policies are.
Ask the same questions.
Find out what their
answers are, and rinse
and repeat until
you find somebody
who fits the bill that
you're looking for.
I don't know if that
answers it, but.
BRANDON: I do want to throw
in one more suggestion, is get
recommendations from other
real estate investors.
I mean, like, anybody you
can find who does this.
And it's fairly
easy to find them,
like I said, at the real
estate clubs or whatever.
Get recommendations.
The hands-down the best
way to know if somebody's
going to be good is to
know if they've been good.
The best way is just reputation.
What have they been to other
people that are similar to you?
So if you can find that
question out, get referrals.
If you ask me, there's five
property managers in my town--
companies in my town--
I'll tell you four of them,
do not go near.
There's one that I would use.
I don't use them yet, but
I will use them someday.
But the other four,
I won't use them.
I'm happy to tell you that,
because I want you to succeed.
Real estate investors
love to help each other.
It's not that competitive of
a business as you might think
Everyone I've ever
known has been open very
open to share and to say,
here, do this, don't do this.
JOSH: And actually, on that
subject of competition,
a lot of new investors will
come out and say, oh, well,
you know, I'm competing--
it kind of goes
to the question about all these
investors jumping on deals.
I'm competing with
all these guys.
Well, people who've been
investing for more than one
or two deals typically
look at their competitors
as collaborators.
You may say, hey Brandon--
you may go and find a deal.
You may do marketing,
send out letters
to people who are in
distressed situations,
and come up with
people, somebody
who's mom just died and needs
to get rid of her property.
And you know what?
You don't have
cash at this point,
because you just bought
another property, right?
So three days later, after
you bought a property,
a phenomenal deal comes in.
Well, you know Brandon's looking
for a similar-type property.
Well, I'm going to work with
Brandon to get the deal done.
I'm not going to make as much
as I might have made otherwise.
But at least I can
make some money,
or at least I can
give it over to him.
He can make some money,
and, you know, payback,
scratchy-scratchy.
So investors like
to work together.
And if you can
collaborate and not
think of the other investors
in your area as competitors,
you're going to do way
better than the folks who do
think that way.
BRANDON: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I can't hear you
guys by the way,
so if someone's asking
a question earlier
I have no idea.
So my question is, so you said
it's really expensive up front
to invest in the Bay
Area for real estate.
Would you recommend for
a first-time investor
to invest locally,
or is it a good idea
to invest in another, less
expensive market at first?
BRANDON: Sure.
This is a really-- this question
comes up all the time, right?
You guys live in a
very expensive area.
People, when we're talking,
they say, well, I live in LA,
I live in San Francisco, I live
in New York, I can't invest.
My belief is that within a
hundred miles of any location
there is good places to invest.
Within a two-hour drive or so
you can get to a good location.
I mean I know like Jordan
bought a property nearby
that actually makes
sense for him.
So I mean, there's
places nearby.
That's probably what
I would recommend.
And again it goes back to
the niche and strategy thing
too, right?
So some niches might be very
difficult in some areas.
Some strategies might
be very difficult.
Like, I'm not-- flipping doesn't
work real well in my area
because prices are really low.
They can't really shoot high.
But around here people,
make millions a year
on flipping houses.
I'm not saying go out and flip
houses, but certain strategies,
certain areas.
So that would be
my thought on that.
Don't know if you
have anything to add.
JOSH: No.
I mean ultimately,
again, you can find deals
whether you're in New
York City, you're in LA,
you're in San Francisco.
Jordan, your property's
out in Sacramento, right?
So what's that?
Two, two plus hours?
I mean, within a
couple hours drive
you can find good deals from
any city in the country.
Now that said, from my
own personal experience,
the first properties I
bought were 2,000 miles away.
Do not do that.
Seriously, don't do that.
Because you can't just get
in your car and get there.
And I can't tell
you how important
that is, at least when
you're starting and learning
about all these things,
and dealing with fires,
because you're going to deal
with fires, no matter what,
in the beginning.
And to be able to get to
those properties, drive by,
see that it's still-- hasn't
been burning down, or whatever.
You want to be able to have
a quick and easy access.
And other questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
My question is [INAUDIBLE].
I buy another property to live
in that I can then convert it.
But now, each time I do that,
the lenders [INAUDIBLE].
Each company has to get smaller
and smaller. [INAUDIBLE].
BRANDON: That's a
really good question.
MALE SPEAKER: Could you
repeat the question?
BRANDON: Yeah, I'll repeat
that question real quick.
He basically said, his
first property he bought,
he lived in the property.
Then he moved and
bought another house.
So he rented the first one out.
Then he did that again.
And you can do that a few times.
But every time you
do it, when you
go to a bank to
try to get a loan,
they're going to only count
part of the income that comes in
towards income.
The bank is going
to say, well, we're
only to give you 75%
of what comes in.
So the more you buy,
the harder it gets.
And this is one of the
really frustrating questions
a lot of investors
have, is pretty soon,
the banks start saying
no, very quickly.
I mean, I got to, I think--
and there's also limits.
Like, a lot of banks say you
cannot have more than four.
We're going to cap you at four.
And so these two
problems, right, I
mean like they're
both kind of related.
Banks will just
have a flat ceiling.
You can't have more than four.
Or your debt to
income it's called,
which is getting a
little complicated,
but your ratios don't work out.
Sorry, you're denied.
What I say is,
for somebody who's
got a little bit of creativity,
and you can work around it.
But my favorite
method of doing this--
this is what I've done
a number of times--
is I work with a partner.
We talked about partners.
This is why I do it.
So what I'll do is
I'll find a partner who
has great credit, great income,
he can qualify for a loan.
He can go into a
bank, he doesn't
own any rental property, really.
But he likes what I do, and
he's got what I don't have,
is the ability to
get another mortgage.
We say, OK, let's
do this together.
We'll use your
income and credit.
I'll find a deal, put
the thing together,
and we'll just split
everything 50/50 later on.
Doesn't have to be 50/50.
You can get what you
need, and negotiate.
But what that
enables is, the bank
doesn't look at me anymore.
They're looking at him.
Even though I'm still on
title on the property,
it's just a nice way to
use somebody else's income
and work together.
You have to find the
right partner to do that,
but that's one way.
Otherwise we can talk
about portfolio loans.
Portfolio loans are how
a lot of investors do it.
I got a portfolio
lender right now, just
a local bank in my area.
And they've flat-out
told me like, oh yeah,
you can get as many
loans as you want.
It's OK.
We don't have a max, because
we keep them in-house.
We're not selling them up to
big Fannie Mae Freddie Mac
institutions that cap
you at a certain number.
As long as the deal
looks OK, we're
going to keep doing them
for you all day long.
JOSH: Yeah and the
portfolio lenders
is-- they're going
to look at the deal.
They're going to
look at the person,
they're going to
look at the deal,
they're going to look
at the experience.
They're going to say,
you know what, Brandon,
you've been doing
this for awhile.
I like the numbers.
You're paying on time.
This next property that
you've got looks great.
Great.
Here's your money.
I mean you'll text your
agent and pick up a deal,
and then you basically send
it over, e-mail it over,
and so next thing you
know you've got the money.
I mean, it really becomes that
easy as you get the experience
if you're working with somebody
who sees what you're doing,
sees that-- but it's not going
to happen when you first start.
But you want to definitely
search out portfolio lenders.
They're definitely going
to be a great asset.
BRANDON: And to find them,
in case you're wondering,
if anybody wants to know
how to find portfolio
lenders-- easiest
way, pick up the phone
and just start calling.
I mean I would
estimate-- I don't
know with these
numbers, numbers,
but I'd estimate 20%
to 30% of all banks
out there are portfolio lenders.
That might be
high, I don't know.
But if you call enough,
like, we interviewed
a guy a couple weeks ago,
he said he called 50 people
and he got one or
two of them to say,
yeah we'll do a loan like that.
We're portfolio lenders.
Not all of them
use that language.
They might not say
portfolio lenders.
But the idea is, do you
keep your loans in-house,
or do you sell them to
Fannie Mae Freddie Mac.
That's what we define
a portfolio lender.
So just call on all of them.
Steer clear of the big banks.
I mean anything that's national
or goes to different states,
those ones aren't going
to be portfolio lenders.
It's the small community banks,
the credit unions, the ones
that you kind of see
in your neighborhood.
They got a dozen,
two dozen branches.
Those are the ones
you want to focus on.
JOSH: You had a question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH: Can you repeat that?
BRANDON: Yeah he's
asking, do you recommend
holding your
properties in an LLC?
I can tell you I personally
do hold them in an LLC,
but I can't say that
that's necessarily
the best thing for everyone.
There are a lot of
different things.
So we have to, you know,
use the disclaimer,
talk to your lawyer, find
out what works for them.
But my lawyer told
me an LLC works well.
JOSH: And I'm again not
going to tell you what to do.
But some people will hold
single properties in an LLC.
Some people will take an LLC
for all their A-type properties,
take another LLC for
all their B-type,
another LLC per partnership.
Or they'll do-- I mean,
there's a million things
that you really can do.
But again, you want to
talk to your attorney
and your accountant
to figure out
what the best structure
for yourself is.
Anyone else?
That's it?
BRANDON: We'll be
around afterwards
if you guys wanna
talk at all, too.
JOSH: Yeah.
Well, thank you guys for coming.
We really appreciate it.
BRANDON: Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]